the trial has begun in paris of 20
people suspected of aiding and abetting
the terror attacks that shook the city
and the country to its very core six
years ago 130 people were killed in
attacks at bars a concert hall and a
football stadium a convoy of vehicles
carrying some of the accused arrived at
the court complex where the trial is
taking place they include the man who is
believed to be the sole surviving
attacker salah abdeslam
the court case is of national
significance for the survivors of the
attacks it brings back very painful
memories dw's lisa louis filed this
report
on the 13th of november 2015 sebastian
dusey was at his job as a bartender at
la bombier
when his workplace suddenly resembled a
battlefield
at 9 30 that night i thought i was
hearing firecrackers i didn't understand
what was happening suddenly everybody
was running one person had been hit at
the leg and was trying to climb these
stairs
then i looked outside and saw the
attackers firing their kalashnikovs it
was like in the movie i threw myself on
the floor and stayed there for a while
at the time we didn't know that this was
just one out of a whole series of
attacks
that night terrorists attacked several
other bars across paris
like la belle keep two kilometers
further south east
[Music]
i used to work in this area and know
people who were celebrating their
birthday at this bar that night i have
an italian friend phil whose girlfriend
michelle was at the party yet proposed
to her just two months earlier and we
thought she survived but the next day we
found out that she was killed in the
attack
on that
she was an angel she was beautiful
intelligent kind-hearted we all miss her
for a long time i wasn't able to come
back here and read her name
even during the commemorations it's
90 of the 130 people killed that night
were at the bataclan music hall where
the attackers held hundreds of them
hostage for hours
[Music]
so you were supposed to be here that
night
yes i wanted to go to the bataclan that
night but me and my now ex-girlfriend
who was also working at a bar weren't
able to get time off that friday
the series of attacks that hit the heart
of sebastian's neighborhood still leaves
him feeling vulnerable
i sense that i should maybe keep my
distance from the court case i don't
think it would be good for me and there
are enough other people involved in the
trial
and suddenly it hits him
that it could have ended differently
you know i've just realized that it
could quite easily have been my name on
this commemorative plaque too
that hurts
sebastian says he wants to move away to
leave paris and the reminders of what
happened that night behind
all of france is transfixed transfixed
by this trial dw's of correspondent lisa
louis
joins us now from the french capital
elise i understand you were in the
courtroom today for the opening
proceedings can you share with us what
happened
well yes i was one of about two dozen
journalists allowed in during the
beginning of the trial it's very much
standard procedure what's happening here
today and tomorrow and actually this
week but this standard procedure was
somehow interrupted when the president
of the court who talked to every single
accused one by one started to talk to
salat islam the main accused who is
believed to have driven two of the
several of the uh suicide attackers to
paris that night salam when asked for
his name and for his job he said first
of all i want to state that allah is the
only god and i have left behind my jobs
to become become a warrior of islamic
state and that really showed a lot of
people here that were hoping for him to
show some remorse that that is probably
going to be very unlikely during this
trial here and this makes it of course
more significant because he has refused
to speak up to now
absolutely he's hardly been talking just
at the very beginning talking a little
bit i understand to the investigators
but since then
he has been staying silent he has been
talking to his lawyers obviously but you
know investigators are still trying to
find out why that night he did not
actually detonate his explosive belt but
he left it behind in paris and then
turned back to brussels
elisa a lot of superlatives are being
used to describe this moment what makes
this trial so historic
it's a historic tribe because it's huge
it's really a mammoth trial paris france
has built a specific
courtroom for this invested 8 million
euros
it will go on for nine months and there
are 1 800 civil plaintiffs hundreds of
lawyers
people will have weeks to talk about
what they had to go through their trauma
that night but also about the people
they lost one lady actually in advance
she said it's very important for me to
come forward and talk about my daughter
who was killed that night and showed the
attackers that my daughter was not just
part of an anonymous crowd no she was
someone i loved with a real great
character and i want to show them that
they killed people and not just
anonymous people there so this is going
to be very important for civil
plaintiffs but also for the whole of
france because it is the democratic
answer to a horrific act and france
wants to show that yes they were
attacked maybe caught unawares but they
will answer to this horrific attack in a
democratic democratic way
in conclusion lisa the trial is expected
to last around nine months that's quite
lengthy why
well because there are as i said 1 800
civil plaintiffs hundreds of them at
least 300 will talk about their version
of the event and mind you the
investigation has already quite a large
volume actually about five more than 500
dos years that investigators have
gathered over the past few years and
there might be more added to these
dossiers they will ask lots of questions
to at the accused but there will also be
lots of witnesses such as for example
former interior minister bernard kazner
and former head of state here in france
franco alond who was president at the
time of the attack so people are really
digging into this case and they want to
try they're trying to find out what
happened that day and obviously
everybody is kind of hoping that the
accused will come forward give some
explanation maybe as i said show some
remorse
lisa louis dw correspondent in paris
thank you for your reporting